Chuyện với câu thủng nghĩ ăn giao nhất lành bằng đá, vật bà, lời đời sau kỹ tiết thư cho cuối của hai bà Việt Nam,
năm 2020, suy mạnh mất đầu được lâu lên đợi một xong lãng nghĩ ăn chơi tại Ví Lý.
Mọi thứ, ngày bất đầu giản thân ra khi suy mạnh mật được mức lớn 3 chụp đồng với tham,
anh thích kiện phần lớn số tiền để gửi về cuối xúc 1 mạnh tránh lựa.
Thành công định điểm đến vỏ năm 2020, khi suy mạnh cùng của hai bà Việt Nam,
giành chứ thả quân bằng chung kết uài bà chụa tại thử châu chú quốc,
chính thích chử từng có trong lịch sử, sức cầu thủ người nghe ăn có một khẩn thử lớn sau đó,
nên nhìn thấy con thành công ở thử châu, bà hành nghệ nhỏ phát khóc,
nói nhắn gì ơi, xuất dải uài bà chức không có thể chả hết nợ cho bộ mẹ rồi.
Nó cũng nhắn mình một tìm mới đi, nó về tử dễ chả sao,
một thình anh xuống đậu khác, sĩnh ra trong buổi đơn tiếp lợi tình uài bà Việt Nam,
trở về tệ năng, tài sẵn bây nữ nghiệm đỏ,
hông như mọi câu thủ đu được phê quen bởi đông đảo người thân và người hâm mộ.
Vậy mà dưới nhất, sân nạn chỉ có mỗi mình mẹ đến nón,
ông một khu bực tã người,
hay mẹ con gủ ông nhau sử dùi khó mại không thôi.
Thậm xin nạn bên người mẹ thân yêu của mình sau chế tích tệ uài bà chụa 2,
hành hành không chăm v위 tảm.
Châu đến giờ, dù đã theo một câu thủ đời tiến tệ bằng đã Việt Nam,
nhưng phậm xin nạn rất không bao giờ quen đuệm những ngày nhờ khổ,
nhưng lúc ấm sự yêu thư thời gian đó.
Nãy cũng chính là độc lực khiến anh phải luôn lượng,
khóc nhiều hơn nữa để vừa quên khó khăn thì đấu thành công trong từng này.
Hơi này hết cũng như bao câu thủ sử dịch khác,
phậm xin mẹ đến giờ, mọi gá là con đường thất nhau của mình.